hello believe nation i am going away
just for a couple weeks i'm going on a
trip to asia i'm gonna hit up uh what
hong kong shanghai beijing south korea
japan
i've been gone for a couple weeks and
uh this is the last video this is the
last video that i'm recording i'm
excited and a little sad too i've got
all my currency exchange i'm packing up
my bags getting everything ready to go
and i wanted just to take a few minutes
to say thank you
for your loyalty for your audience ship
for the comments you leave uh of all the
things that you know i'm excited to go
i'm excited to travel and see these
places
um first time to a lot of those areas
but
of all the things i'm gonna miss
you guys are thinking i miss most uh the
daily comments you know waking up and
and eating my lentils and looking at the
youtube comments just fills me with
energy and excitement for the day gets
me ready to go and i'm going to miss
that i'm going to miss having you guys
there with me every morning
so i just want to say thank you i have
some videos scheduled that will be
coming out while i'm away so you still
get to see me
please leave the comments you know again
i'll come back and be inundated and i'll
have a comment fest uh but don't freak
out if i don't respond to anything over
the next couple weeks it'll be away no
newsletter going out no comments uh but
there will be some new videos so i'm
heading out thank you so much and i'll
see in a couple weeks believe
you